wir wollen jetzt gleich ins kanzleramt
schauen zu angela merkel
heute sind es alleine 45 landkreise
unter 35 und deutlich über 100
landkreise unter 50 wir haben zwar ein
verlangsamtes tempo der es runter geht
es aber wir gehen beständig runter
bisher die zahl der intensivbetten sie
belegt ist ist immer noch 800 mehr als
im maximum des frühjahrs aber immerhin
2000 weniger als ende dezember anfang
januar
und wenn wir uns diese entwicklung
angucken könnte man sehr zufrieden sein
jetzt können auch sehr zufrieden sein
ich möchte den bürgerinnen und bürgern
danken die das durch ihr verhalten
gerade auch im privaten bereich aber
auch durch viele home office durch
weniger reisen ermöglicht haben
denen gebührt unser dank und es zeigt
sich dass die verhängten maßnahmen die
ja oft sehr strikt auf sehr hart auf
sehr mühselig sind doch ihre wirkung
zeigen
heute wollten wir nun diskutieren wie es
weitergeht und wir müssen leider dies im
lichte einer entwicklung tun die wir
alle im vergangenen jahr noch nicht
voraussehen konnten nämlich in der
entwicklung einer oder verschiedene
mutationen des virus wir haben den
ersten bericht über diese veränderten
viren bekommen durch sequenzierungen die
in deutschland in ende am ende januar
durchgeführt wurden
damals ist ein prozentsatz von 57
prozent der britischen variante im
wesentlichen und weniger fälle der
südafrikanischen variante uns
vorgestellt worden
wir
wissen dass diese mutationen also jetzt
eine realität ist und damit wird sie zu
nehmen
die frage ist wie schnell nimmt sie zu
und wir wissen dass unser erfolg nicht
unter 0,7 licht er liegt meistens bei
0,85
wenn diese variante um 0,3 aggressiver
ist dann würde unser reproduktions fährt
wieder bei über 1 liegen das heißt wir
würden sehr schnell im exponentiellen
wachstum sein
deshalb ist da eine dritte welle
angelegt die wir bekämpfen müssen und
die können wir nur bekämpfen wenn wir
einen incident zahlen wirklich runter
kommen wenn die gesundheitsämter wieder
die kontrolle über das virus bekommen in
dem sinne dass sie die kontakte
nachverfolgen können dann können wir
auch bei lockerungsschritte die inzidenz
weiter senken und das ist ja das was wir
wollen und deshalb ist es die zeitspanne
zwischen jetzt und mitte märz bei uns
die experten sagen dass die mutierten
viren die oberhand gewinnen könnten über
das bisherige virus diese zeitspanne ist
so existenziell dass wir da weiter
unsere instanzen senken oder deshalb
müssen wir auch sehr vorsichtig sein
neben der kontakt nach verfolgung für
die gesundheitsämter spielen hier
übrigens auch die erweiterten
testmöglichkeiten eine rolle denn wir
haben natürlich ganz anders als im
frühjahr inzwischen durch die
schnelltest und vielleicht bald auch
durch die selbsttests möglichkeiten der
überwachung die wir sonst nicht hatten
wir wollen alles tun damit wir nicht in
eine wellenbewegung hoch und runter auf
und zu kommen sondern indem wir
vorsichtig unsere öffnungen und
lockerungen machen immer unter der
maßgabe dass wir beobachten müssen
welcher schritt hat welche auswirkung
und was bedeutet das dann für die
entwicklung der fallzahlen
wir haben immer wieder
wir haben heute noch einmal deutlich
gemacht dass bestimmte maßnahmen
erhalten bleiben die kontakte
beschränkungen nicht notwendige private
und reisen und besucher sollen
unterlassen werden und die aufforderung
zum home office die auch bis zum 15 märz
gilt vorerst die soll sehr ernst
genommen werden
wir wissen dass bildung priorität hat
das haben wir alle immer wieder gesagt
und deshalb sind die bereiche von kita
und schule von äußerster bedeutung
ich habe bestimmte eigene vorstellungen
gehabt über das öffnen von
kindertagesstätten und tagesstätten und
auch schulen die er auf eine öffnung um
den ersten märz also zum ersten märz
ging weil ich glaube dass wir dieses
datum sehr voraussehbar anpeilen können
für eine instanz von 50 aber ich weiß
auch dass wir in einem föderalen staat
leben und der föderalismus ist unter dem
strich die beste war die bessere ordnung
als ein zentralismus davon bin ich
zutiefst überzeugt selbst wenn es
manchmal etwas mühsam ist und es gibt
ganz ganz eindeutige und tief stehen
tief verankerte blender zuständigkeiten
das sind schule und kita
und da ist es ganz einfach nicht möglich
dass ich als bundeskanzlerin mich so
durchsetzen kann als hätte ich da ein
veto recht wie das zum beispiel in der
europäischen union bei einstimmigkeit
möglich ist und deshalb haben wir gesagt
die kultur hier und die länder werden
das in eigener verantwortung und
sicherlich dann auch noch dargestellt
durch die ländervertreter entscheiden
wir liegen da gar nicht so weit
auseinander für mich ist nur diese
instanz von 50 als ein leitfaden sehr
wichtig und da wir sonst ein großes
hohes maß an einigkeit haben haben wir
diese beschlüsse jetzt auch so gemeinsam
gefasst wie sie hier wieder gelingt sind
wir haben es entschieden dass friseure
zum ersten märz öffnen werden eben
gerade weil zu diesem tag dann auch mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit eine 15 cds
deutschlandweit zu erreichen ist wir
haben darüber gesprochen wie sehen denn
nächste eröffnung schritte aus und bei
diesen nächsten eröffnungs schritten ist
ja sehr wichtig dass wir perspektiven
aufzeigen auf der einen seite aber auf
der anderen seite natürlich auch immer
damit leben müssen dass wir die zukunft
nicht voraussagen können und deshalb
haben wir gesagt aus heutiger
perspektive insbesondere vor dem
hintergrund der unsicherheit bezüglich
der verbreitung von virus mutter kann
der nächste öffnungs schritt bei einer
stabilen sieben tage instituts von
höchstens 35 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner rund 100 durch die länder
erfolgen
dieser nächste öffnungs schritt soll die
öffnung des einzelhandels mit einer
begrenzung von einer kundin oder im
kunden 20 quadratmeter umfassen
dazu die öffnung von museen und galerien
sowie die öffnung der noch geschlossenen
körpernahen dienstleistungsbetriebe es
müssen dann natürlich wenn das länder
weit gemacht wird mit den nachbarländern
auch entsprechende vorkehrungen
getroffen werden dass es nicht zu einem
einkaufstourismus kommt wir werden dann
für die weiteren bereiche die wir hier
auch nennen nämlich kontakt
beschränkungen im persönlichen bereich
kultur sport in gruppen freizeit
gastronomie und hotelgewerbe schritt für
schritt weitere öffnung schritte
vereinbart
aber dieser erste größere schritt nach
schule und friseurin ist dann einer den
wir bei einer konstanten stabilen
incidents von höchstens 35 neue
infektionen gehen und ich glaube das ist
etwas woran auch jeder orientieren kann
manche sagen das ist
ein so niedriger wert kann man den
erreichen und darauf will ich noch mal
auf meine eingangs bemerkung hinweisen
wir haben in den vergangenen tagen der
25 januar ist nicht ewig her 43 punkte
ins ident sind darunter gegangen von 50
auf 35 sind es 15 punkte das heißt beim
weiteren sinkenden verlauf das heißt
natürlich müssen alle anderen
restriktionen auch einheiten kann man
das durchaus erreichen und das ist in
einer reichweite wir haben dann über das
impfen gesprochen über die weitere
unterstützung der altenpflegeheime und
andere punkte die sich jetzt die
einzelnen ausführen dieses in unserem
beschluss dargestellt ich will nur noch
einmal darauf hinweisen dass heute der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
eine ankündigung machen konnte die
sehnlichst und dringend erwartet wurde
nämlich zu den überbrückungshilfen 3
seit heute mittag oder nachmittag können
diese online beantragt werden
damit wurde auch der zeitplan der in
aussicht gestellt wurde eingehalten
die antragsteller werden innerhalb
weniger tage er legt sich fest
spätestens bis zum 15 februar in einem
automatisierten verfahren großzügige
abschlagszahlung in höhe von bis zu
400.000 euro erhalten 100.000 pro monat
und die endgültigen bescheide erfolgen
dann durch die länder ab dem monat märz
ich glaube das ist für viele die echte
große liquiditätsprobleme haben und
natürlich auch sonderopfer bringen jetzt
im zusammenhang mit der compagnie eine
wichtige und sehnlichst erwartete
mitteilung die wir heute machen können
das von meiner seite zu unseren heutigen
beschlüssen wir werden uns am dritten
märz wieder treffen und dann weitere
fragen natürlich besprechen und vor
allem die situation analysieren
angesichts der des zunehmenden anteils
der mutation wird man dann die lage
wieder bewerten müssen deshalb finde ich
das datum
man hat sehr gut das heißt die von uns
heute gefassten beschlüsse gilt gelten
erst mal bis zum 7
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren